feel sorry for a little bit after
hearing that because now she's going to
a dating coach when she should coach
herself like as a you know get
experience I'm sorry for someone who put
their themselves in there I said a
little bit because because I feel like
she's she's actually I don't know she
also had the cheek to say um
I'm not that interested in jewelry even
after she recorded 200. she was like
yeah but you know what that's it right
I'll be made yeah I would hope I would
hope that you don't require anything
like no presence for ever 200k oh my God
I think like because I did say that I
feel sorry for her so I think I'll
answer that question from my point of
view I think it's coming from a place
where
I think she doesn't know better and
she's on her journey
of whatever it is and I feel sad that
yeah I I I pity her it's it's I I I I I
would I would hope that people would
find more meaningful things in a
relationship Beyond and an unrealistic
number at all because I just think
that's an excuse like you're 30 years
old you don't you don't know I don't
pick you up
yeah that's the thing like men men hit
reality hard they're rejected by that
girl at 16 in math class she lets the
whole class know but she turns you down
because she looks better if she could
turn down more guys and so so reality
hits men hard where women it's like we
choose to live in delusion and it's a
choice because clearly if she's never
had a boyfriend there's been no takers
I'm not saying that's my I'm I'm not
saying that I'm relieving her of her own
like I'm not saying that she shouldn't
take responsibility for her life and her
choices and the way she presented
herself I agree yeah
it's a it's just my personal way of
reacting to things I understand I'm just
a very empathetic person so
I I think I would want everyone to be on
a great place I wouldn't want anyone to
be discriminated or
being treated poorly and that's why I'm
upset because
I I really feel for people who are being
somehow told you're not good enough
because you can't get I'm sorry you're
sorry that's just that's just me I it's
not I'm not generalizing for everyone
that's just a personal thing and I feel
it's really sad that these people exist
this is what I think it's important
um see I'm not mad I'll keep it 100 if
you as a male getting upset about that
I would have a different reaction to you
the fact that you're a female again I've
said that I can understand that and this
is why I also encourage men not to be
too emotional because emotional men
would accept what she's asking for and
end up laughing her and yes the Snowball
Effect you you you have a woman out
there asking for a million requirements
and if you're a man that feels sorry for
them type of women you start wife and
them type of women encouraging more
women to have a list of even more
requirements and then Men start with him
as well so it's important that I think
we understand the difference that you're
a female getting upset about that that's
fine if there's a man getting upset by
that that would almost encourage him to
accept what she's asking for do you
think if you've said this before to
bring back bullying if you think if she
was bullied bruh it would solve so many
problems it would solve so no I'm
serious I'm serious none of y'all have
been humbled you know what my brother
told me I had a big nose until I was 22.
22. and you know what it humbled me okay
I don't know I have a great nose right
thank you thank you but but literally my
brother my brother probably the time I
was a kid but you'd always tell me I was
ugly and honestly I feel like it kept me
down to earth no no no yeah that would
be better right good and you know what I
was I was fat
I got on the treadmill you know what I
mean that's your problem bro that's what
I'm saying I'm like if someone is like
that's how to say when I watch it back
I'm like I wish I was a little bit more
direct but I was in shock I don't know
if you saw my face I was like
it's you you know you used that to
actually fuel yourself to do the right
thing instead of feeling sorry for
yourself yeah no that's what that's what
I think too I mean the problem with that
is um every person internalizes and
deals with trauma differently so it's
some people do it exactly the way you do
it so you you enter you actually make
into Fuel and you make it useful the
problem is there are a lot of people who
don't and that's what we end up with
situation where suicide happens because
people cannot get out of it and it
spirals out of control and I think
that's that's the thing like everyone's
an individual you walk process your
trauma differently
um
I was bullied and it was horrible and
yes I understand that
the bully was bullied as well it was a
cycle she then felt that in order to
feel better about herself she's going to
bully her her own her own people who are
under her and
and she was Infamous for it and it was
it's so sad it got so many people
mentally and well work related stress
people who had to go people just left
because they it was it wasn't well and I
have I know there were people that I
worked with who still cannot go back to
that workplace because if they're near
it she goes into a panic attack and I
think in general tough times build tough
people perfect that's what I think like
I mean like yeah some people take
process it differently but I just think
in general we're in a place in society
where no one can handle criticism ever
and it's like any I mean how do you
think I deal with the comments all the
time I have girls roasting every part of
my appearance right now my insta I don't
care yeah my brothers did that for me
the first time the same people that
pretty uh body positivity yeah it's the
whales the whales are coming the whales
are coming like I just think that tough
times breed test people
it does um but I think again that that
depends on the personality
and I personally have and I still deal
with mentally and well patients and I
can tell you it's it's very sad at the
the different stories that go to the
horrors they've lived through from
childhood and onwards and
the honest truth is you cannot just tell
them to suck it up and deal with it
because it is trauma and
what else do you do though like like
because it's like it's kind of like if
you don't like like what what are you
supposed to do I mean I understand like
you go so that's maybe you talk about it
can I ask a question so then like you go
through the trauma you talk about it but
then it's like what now like the only
the only thing you can do is move
forward so it's about realizing so for
example the idea of triggering right I
don't understand what the whole idea of
trigger warning is I think as you say
it's like trying to cater to a certain
amount of people who can't deal with the
fact that they are triggered by
something the important thing about
being triggered is that actually
whatever is triggering you is a
statement it's neutral and you are being
triggered because you for some reason
have some type of trauma because of that
so
for example it's very personal but one
of the things I saw online uh different
uh YouTuber the guys were saying exactly
the same if you're a girl over if you've
if you are a girl who
have been single for a certain amount of
time that's a red flag
and the first time I heard that I was
triggered I was like oh my God like what
and and rather than react which a lot of
people do a lot of girls then they lash
out and they're horrible I say to myself
no no why are you triggered
and I was like because he's he's saying
truth because guess what when you meet
someone
first impression is your innate alarm
system you need that to try and you know
protect yourself it's part it's natural
to have an alarm now of course it's
important to then
when you get to know someone because you
can't always judge a book by the cover
so it's important to take the red flags
but don't run with it and take it beyond
that all and so I asked myself why on
Earth are you triggered
because you shouldn't be it's a
statement and I said it's because I've
been single for a while and guess what
it's triggering me because I don't want
to I I don't want to be single if you
know it's mostly and and this is the
thing so I realized hey so well what are
you gonna do about it well why don't you
work on yourself why don't you work on
your femininity why don't you work on
making yourself the best version you can
so that maybe when you when the right
person come in then you're at the right
energy to be with that person if you
notice most people are triggered by the
truth like you said so if someone says
something about it that's not true that
wouldn't trigger me personally I don't
think if someone says oh you're this
you're done it's not true okay like if
someone if someone called you short you
wouldn't care
but I don't know because like I always
think about when we talk about trauma
like what is trauma because all
throughout all of human history we're
all involved in like Wars starvations
plagues and now it's like we talk about
like trauma being okay you're bullied a
little bit as a kid like I just feel
like our ancestors would look at us and
laugh it's because because throughout
all of human history we had horrible
lives yeah and nobody had to like talk
like go to a psychologist